صار قصف للمربع كامل ضربوا المربع كامل
بثلاث صواريخ طبعا على
اثرها ضرر ضرر بيت اخويا واستشهد ابني
طبعا وبنت اخويا وزوجه ابويا وصار في
اقتراح من زوجي اني انا اطلع على الجنوب
اكال الوضع خطر في المعسكر صار زياده عن
اللزوم يعني قصف مدفعي عنيف لكل المناطق
فطلعنا يوم اربعاء
22/11 لما وصلنا لعند الحاجز العسكري طبعا
كله ينزل
وطابور وطبعا لما رفعنا الهوايا صاروا
طبعا ينادوا على كل شخص مش بالاسم لا
الشخص الشاب اللابس جاكيت اسود على اصفر
يجي عندي حكوا على بنتي اسيل نادوا عليها
قها البنت اللابسه شاله بيضا تيجي لعندي
هنا وحمله شنته طبعا بعد ما نادوا على
مجموعه من الاشخاص حقولنا يلا تفضلوا
ادخلوا انتظرتها لحد الساعه اعه ونص بعد
العصر وما حدا طلع اذا شخص يعني شخصين
كاينين سامعين اخبار حقول لي انا كل يوم
بكون موجود في هذا المكان في هذا الوقت
بعد هذا الوقت ما بطلعوا حدا لو بم طلعوا
حدا كان طلعوه قبل الساعه عه واحنا ما بدي
اصدمك يعني وانا ما كنت لحالي كان معي
كمان عائلتين او ثلاثه بيستنوا برضه في
بناتهم ما بدي اصدمك بس انا سمعت بالاخبار
قبل شويه ان هم اخذوا رهائن من الناس عشان
لضمان تنفيذ الهدنه زي دروع بشريه وان شاء
الله بتطلع في ايام
الهدنه يوم الخميس
بالضبط اليوم اللي هو الاخير للهدنه كانت
الجمعه ما هي خلص اتصلت علي طبعا بنت اختي
من خلال هم بالخارج يعني اولاد اختي
بالخارج وهم اللي بيجيبون لي المعلومات
هنا ما في تواصل مع اي مؤسسه ا تواصلت
واتصلت علي وحكتلي يعني انه هي موجوده
حولوها على سجن
الدامون من ضمن عشر اسيرات تخيل تدخل سجن
يعني انت هلقيت مش حتطلع او ممكن يسجنها
اداري مثلا
سجن اداري او يطلعو لها اي تهمه مع هي
مالهاش علاقه باي حاجه يعني هي كان بس
دراستها يعني هي كان اهتمام بستها كانت هي
نفسها هي صغيره تصير
طبيبه لاخر فتره كانت حاطه في م اصير
طبيبه نفسيه بحاول اكون
قويه وبدعي ربنا دائما
ثبتني
دموعي هذه مش دموع ضعف ولا
الكساره لكن هذ دموع الم لا بنتي انا مش
عارفاها ولا زوج انا مش قادره اتواصل
معه ولا حتى اهل اطمن
عليهم
وراي في كثف لا راح خلص وين مخص اليوم
بخلص لتنا ليله
الليله بعيد ايوه بعيد صح هناك
هناك